よろしくお願いします
今日は悟りということについて
第2回目のお話でございます
第1回目のお話で諦めないで 2
回目にも参加していただけましたことは大変勇気のあることだと思いますけど
これは本当に理解できているように錯覚はするんだけど
なかなか理解しにくいテーマでもあります
うーん とにかく何とか理解させようと思うと
その結果として誤解してしまうということもあります
で このお釈迦様おっしゃっているこの人間体験するべき人間の目的としてするべき
この解脱 涅槃という境地
あの あの悟りといっても
一般的な日本語で言っている悟りは何ですか？というテーマで
私は喋っているわけではありません
お釈迦様おっしゃっているニッバーナということについて話してますので
涅槃ですね その人間が至るべき
体験するべき 努力するべき目的としたべきするべき境地だと言っている
この悟りという そういうものが
なかなかこの研究している人々も
どういうものかと理解していないんですね
それで では伝統的な解釈の世界で
仏教の中で 仏教の中でも学問的なものがございますから
その中で理解しているかというと
そちらはもう最初からもう諦めているんですね
経典じゃなくて 注釈書などを読んでみると
それはもうこんな頭で理解するものではないんだと
これは究極的な境地で
人間はその次元でいないんだから
これは努力して自分で体験するものであると
個人個人で頑張って理解するものであって
それについて喋ったりして
ああ よくわかりましたとかね
そういう感じのものでもないと
そういうふうに言っても
人間っていうのはそんな説明では納得いくわけではありません
まあいいものだと でも説明してもわかりませんと
頑張ってみてくださいと言っても
誰がやるんですかね やっぱりいくらかは説得させなくてはならないんですね
ですから 理解しにくいと言いながらも
なぜ涅槃というものを体験
解脱というものは体験しなくたしなくてはならないのかと
やっぱり説得させなくちゃいけないんですね
そこでお釈迦様がとった手段は
すごく客観的な手段で
あなたの今の状態はどういうことかと観察してみなさいと
私の今 自分の普通の生き方
あるいは他の生命の生き方
世の中のこと この客観的に離れてきちんとありのままに見てみなさいと
何が発見するんですかと
それで それをお釈迦様に説明できますからね
あなたはいくら頑張って発見し
頑張って探求しても 見つかるのはドゥッカのみですよと
不満のみですよと 不安だけですよと
あれは違う言葉で言えば無常
変化していくんだ 実態はどこにもないんだ
ありがたいものはどこにもないんだということを発見するはずですよと
だから解脱を目指して頑張れと
それで我々にはこの我々生きてる世界のことはいろんな角度から見ることはできます
それもありのままで見てほしい
ある お釈迦様はドゥッカですよと
苦しみですよと言ったんだからといって
その目で見ますよと言ったら
それは正しい見方じゃないんです
例えば世の中 もうなんだかんだもあれもドゥッカだ
これもドゥッカだ あれもドゥッカだ
そんな感じで見ると 自分が色眼鏡付いて見ているんだから
つけて見ているんだからね
それも正しい見方ではありません
そこでもし人々は徹底的に世の中
そうやって苦しいものだと
嫌なものだと その色眼鏡で見ると
それははっきりしたペシミズムですね
ペシミズムというのは一つの極論であります
その事実はそのまま説明するものではありません
ですから 気をつけてほしいのは
お釈迦様 自分の探求の結論として
自分の研究の結果としてドゥッカですよという結論を出してます
そこでこれ科学的なやり方だから
はいわかりましたと認めるわけにはいきません
ある科学者が何かこういうものだよと何か発見したら
みんなそうですよというわけにはいきません
そこで他の人々もそうですかと
実験してみなくてはならないんですね
そこで誰が実験しても同じ結果になるならば
これはしょうがないことなんです
ですから この信仰を信じる話ではないんですね
とにかく仏教と科学というのは
両方の信じる世界の話ではないんです
だから 一応お釈迦様は最初の科学者として
最初の発見者として 最初に研究した人の研究レポートとして
ドゥッカですよというレポートを出してるんです
我々に もし我々はそれを信じて鵜呑みにして
その目で世の中を見るとどうなるかというと
お釈迦様の真理に至るところではなくて
単なるペシミズムに陥ってしまうんですね
だからそこら辺 仏教というのはなんかすごく
この何て言いますか タイトロープウォーキングと言いますね
あれはなんて言いますか
日本語で タイトロープウォーキング
綱渡り みたいなもんなんですね
きちんとバランスを取って進まないと
落ちてしまうんですね
だから不思議なこと すべての世の中のものは
すべてのものは苦しみですよと言っているにも関わらず
仏教はペシミズムではありません
そうすると なんか理屈合わないんじゃないかなと思う可能性もあります
お釈迦様が言うのは ヤターブータンパッサティ
ヤターブータンパッサティ
ありのままに見ることですね
これ いつでも私は書く言葉なんですね
ヤターブータンパッサティ
ヤターブータンというのはありのままに
事実に観察する パッサティというのは観察する
だからありのままに見ると
あの 何て言いますか ペシミズムにもオプティミズムにも陥りません
で ペシミズムは悲観主義と言うんですか？何でしたっけ？悲観主義？悲観主義者にもならないし
楽観主義者にもならないはずなんです
例えば お釈迦様は弟子たちにものの見方説明する場合は
こうやって見なさいと
[背景音]どんなものでも
これは弟子たちに言ってることね
世の中のことを観察する場合は
一番目アッサーダという立場見てください
アッサーダっていうのはベネフィッツ
いいところいいとこ これ欲に対してなんですけど
五欲に対してなんですけど
どんなものにもあるいいところがありますね
そこはそのまま あ これはいいものだと見てほしいと
それだけじゃないんだと
物にはアーディーナ悪いところもありますと
トラブルもありますと
同じものに それから三番目にニッサーラナ
じゃあ こういういいところもあって
悪いところもあって このものについては
だからそこに関わりない
何か他の第三次元の何か立場がないかと
いわゆるそれから離れることオンリーですね
離れたらどうですかと
その立場も考えてくださいと
ですから 世の中を観察すると
3つの角度で世の中を見てほしいんですね
そうすると一つ丸めて世の中を見たことになるんです
だからこのペシミズムと言いにくいんですね
皆様に分かりやすい具体的な例で言うならば
例えば今現在 社会ではお金という現象がありますね
お金どうですかと そしたら
いきなりこれはいいものだよと結論するのは科学的じゃないんですね
そこでまずお金のいいとこを考えてみるんですね
便利なところ あ こういうこういう便利なところあります
こういうこういう大変役に立つところありますと
そこを観察してみる それからそちらの悪いところも観察してみる
それからそれと全く関係ない
もっとすごい高いレベルで
そういうものに関わりない状態はどういうことかとも考えなくてはならないんですね
だから結構観察のレベルっていうのは
もうなかなか大変な高いレベルなんですね
例えばお金についてまた説明しますけど
例えばあれば一応便利なもので
今の社会では人間にとって必要なものはかなり物質的なものはかなりお金で揃うんですね
お金で揃うのはほとんど物質的なもの
家を買えるし 服を買えるし
食べ物を買えるし それからいろいろ体を楽しめようと思ったら
旅行行ったり いろんなことをしたり
それもお金でできるんですね
そういういいところはあります
悪いところって何ですかね
まず分かりやすいのはあればいいんだけど
これに入りますかね 簡単に
これ獲得することはものすごく難しいんです
お金だけは自動的に自分の方向へ流れてこないんですね
悪いことだったら勝手に入ってくるんです
全く自動的に入ってこないのは
世の中でただそれだけ
お金だけなんですね 例えば病気だったら嫌でも入ってくるんですね
嫌でも入ってくるんです
だからなんかすごい側面を持ってるんですね
なんか人間のことを嫌いみたいで
自分のことを嫌いみたいで逃げようとしているのしているんだけど
入ろうとは全然していない
それで私たちはそれ得るために大変苦労しなくてはならないんですね
そこで得たところで まあこれ楽しいんですね
得たならば 得たところでこれを管理する
あるいは守るという 2つの問題が出てくるんですね
やっと入ったものだから
いい加減に使っちゃえば
もうそれで自分の望ましい結果が出てこないんですね
だから管理しなくちゃいけない
それで守らなくてはならないっていうことを二番目のこと
なぜならば 生えたお金
いつでも逃げていこう
逃げていこうとばっかしなんです
こんなちょっと不注意で逃げてしまいますからね
もう財布でもどこかに置いといて行ってみてください
もう帰るとないんですね
じゃあ自分の使っていた服とかね
他のものをどこかに置いてみてください
次の日に来たってもあるんです
不思議でしょうね あれだけすぐ逃げちゃうんです
そこで自分のところにあると思ったら
自分の命まで危ないということもありますね
そういうふうに このまあ
そこは一般的なもので
もう考えてみれば まあいいところも確かにある
人間に楽しいことは確かにしてくれる
同時に人間に大変心配
危険も作ってくるものなんですね
その二つはわかりやすい
わかりにくいのはニッサラの側面なんですね
じゃあ お金から全く離れた状態ってどういう状態かというと
一般的に頭に浮かぶのは
じゃああの野生に戻ったらいいんじゃないかとか
そういう話ではないんですね
野生に戻ったらいいやというのは
それは科学的な知識的な答えではありません
そこに生きるということはどういうものかということは考えなくちゃいけない
生きる上では 社会と関係を持たなくちゃならない
社会と関係を持つ場合は
お金は絡んでくると そこで自分がなぜそんなに生きたがりますかとかね
そこら辺に考え方を持っていかなくちゃいけないんです
ですから 結構難しいんです
だから このお坊さんたちに出家者に言ってるのは
あの世の中みんな言ってるように
これはいいものやと言っただけで
もう決めつけるんじゃなくて
やっぱりいろんな側面を考えて行動した方がよろしいんですね
例えばニッサラのわからなくてもアッサデの方がベネフィッツの方がいいところを考えてみる
それで悪いところも考えてみる
そこで引き算してみたら
いいところの方が多ければ
まあ別に実行してみたってもよろしいし
悪いところの方が多いんだったら
これやめた方がいいと
だから仏教の道徳世界もだいたいそこら辺で成り立ってるんですね
わかりやすいれば 例えばまあ麻薬はどうですかと
まあいいところもあります
麻薬にも あれ使った途端
もう大変気持ちよくて
ものすごい快楽感で楽しいんだそうですね
そこはもうすごい忘れられないほど楽しみみたいですね
そこでどれぐらいそこは長持ちするかというと
まあわかる 私はあまり実際のことを知りませんだからあまりわかりませんだけど
普通の薬飲んだっても
まあせいぜい 1時間  2時間間での薬の結果が消えちゃうでしょ
例えばいろいろ薬飲んだら
ちょっと眠くなったりとかね
そういう薬もありますね
で 眠くもなってしまう
風邪薬のようなものを飲んでも
30分ぐらい ほんのちょっと頭が眠くてあるんだけど
それでそれ消えてしまうんですね
いわゆるそこを体分解してしまいますからね
その物質を ですから もしかすると麻薬の場合も
30分 1時間  2時間以内でしょうと思いますけどね
で それはいい結果なんですね
そこで それから得られるアディーナワの方を考えると
どうですかと  社会から抹殺される
法律で捕まれる いろいろなことがありますね
すごいお金かかってしまう
そこで依存する なくてはならない状態になる
世の中のことをどうでもいいことになる
家族のこと 社会のこと
仕事のこと そんなものはどうでもいいということになる
とにかく人間としての破壊の道に行ってしまっちゃうんですね
そこでわかりやすいんですね
自分が廃人になるか  30分の快楽感感じるかと
ですから 人の 80年間生きると思ったら
80年間の人生を捨てて 30分の快楽感得るかというと
これわかりやすい計算でしょう
だからそんなことはやる必要はないんですね
だから一方的にやめなさい
地獄に落ちるんだという話でもないんです
ちゃんと自分で計算して考えればいいもんなんですね
そこで仏教でこの道徳として倫理学としてやめなさいと言っているものは
そういう計算の結果なんですね
例えば嘘をつくなという話がありますね
嘘をついて我々は得る結果っていうのは瞬間的なんですね
その時だけ人を騙す でも言ったのは事実ではありませんだから
これ誰にでも発見できますね
事実だから事実を これ世の中そういうものだから
私は嘘を 嘘を言ったならば
言ったことは存在しないものでしょうに
だから 言われた側が調べたら必ずしも事実を発見するでしょう
だから あるものはないと言ったんだから
ないものはあると言ったんだから
嘘っていうのはそういうことだから
だから嘘っていうのは一旦ついた時
ついた瞬間からいつでもバレる恐れがありますね
だからその瞬間で自分が良かったんだよ
嘘を言って でもその日からその人死ぬまで自分言ったことをバレると
その恐れが絡んでくるんです
自分先に死んだ ああ良かったということじゃないんです
言われた側が死ぬまでまた続くんです
あの死んだ奴に騙されたんだと
地獄に落ちた方がいいんだと言われる可能性ありますね
だから 瞬間の快楽感にするために一生かかるかと
一生で払って瞬間の快楽感得るかというと
それは無知な行動でしょうに
だからそれはもうダメと
やめてくださいと そこはお釈迦様はご自分で計算して
自分の電卓で一応リストを作ってあるんですね
今の人々に頼んだら ご自分でやってみてください
計算してみてください
全然もう計算できないんですね
いまだに言うんで いるんですよ
人々はやっぱり嘘も方便だよという
バカどもがいるんです
さっぱりもう観察能力ないんです
方便だと言って嘘をついたっても
それからひどい目に遭いますからね
子供に嘘をつくでしょうに
どれほど親子関係それでガタガタになるかと
それは気にしない その瞬間で嘘をついて
それから一生苦しみのようになってしまっちゃうんですね
だから嘘は方便ではありません
嘘は嘘だけなんです それはこの鼻先の快楽感だけ考える人々が
それから知識能力ない人々のうわごとなんですね
鋭い観察能力ある人 よく頭を切れる人だったら嘘は言わないんです
例えば真実を語ったら良くないと分かったところで
それは言わないで ちゃんと他の言うべきことを言うんですね
例えばこれを言いなさいと
断りますと 言いませんと
それだけのことでしょうに
こういうこういうことをあんた知ってるでしょうと
はい 知ってます じゃあ何ということか
いえ 言いませんと 言う権利も言わない権利も人間にありますから
私は言いませんと言っても構いません
それはちょっと頑固な態度かもしれませんし
まあ他のことを言ってね
まあそんなことを聞いたってもね
結局役に立たんでしょうしね
大したことはないんだとね
そのままでいいんじゃないかと
言って その人に他のこと言ったっても
それは構いませんし ですから
この そういう能力ない人は
やっぱりこれを本当このこと言ったらちょっとまずいと分かったところで嘘をついてしまっちゃう
その瞬間ではもう無事安全問題解決しますけど
それから一生それ引っかかってくるんですね
苦しみとして まあとにかくですから
世の中で生きる場合は一応そうやっていろんなあの３つのアスペクトが一番わかりやすいんだから書いたんだけど
またいろいろあります
また調べれば 経典なんかはね
そういうわけで 決して仏教はこのペシミズムでもオプティミズムでもどちらでもない
楽観主義でも悲観主義でもないんですね
何主義でもないんです
何も言えないんだから
例えば私に聞いたって
お金っていいものですか？悪いものですか？わかりません
そんなことは 全然わかりません
その場でその場では言えます
例えば 私はバスに乗ろうとする
それであなたどう思いますかね？お金のことは
やっぱり役に立ちますね
いいもんだね その時は言うんです
200円払わなくちゃいけないんだから
私はお布団に入って寝ようとする
お金のことをどう思いますか？どうでもいいんだと
もう寝るんだから その時はどうでもいいんです
お金があってもなくても寝られますからね
ですから このそのそれぞれの条件において
この一時的な判断はできます
一つも永遠な普遍的な判断ではありません
だから そういうふうな世の中見てみなさいと
そこでどんどん次元高くして
レベル高くして 厳密に物事を観察して欲しかったんですね
そこでこの五欲に対してお釈迦様がおっしゃったことは
解脱の方に行きますけど
例えば見るもの 聞くもの
味わうもの 嗅ぐもの 体で感じるもの
その 5つの欲の世界欲世間
見ると確かに楽しみがありますと
子供がいて楽しいと 財産があって楽しいと
友達がいて楽しいと 健康で楽しいと
幸福だと 家族がいて楽しいと
そういう楽しみは確かにあるんですよと
でもお釈迦様が言うのはアッパッサーダ
このアッサーダなんです
このアッサーダという言葉はこちらにアッパッサーダという言葉でお釈迦様は結論を出しちゃうんですね
アッパっていうのは少々という Little
ほんのちょっとだよと
アッパッサーダカーマーウッターバガヴァタという
偈を全部言うならば ですから
この我々のこの世俗的な世の中に
確かに楽しみ 幸福がありますけど
これはほんのちょっとですよと
あるのは そこで 2番目アーディーナ
そちらにお釈迦様が言うのはバフアーディーナは
バフアーディーナはバフっていうのはたくさん
だから人はもう何やってもいいんだけど
これ例えるなら 書くならばこんな感じになるんですよ
だからアーディーナの方が大きくて
アッサードの方が小さくなりますね
あのパーリ語の言葉で言っているのはそういうことなんです
世の中のことを観察すると
アーディーナの方が大きいんだと
苦しみの方が大きいんだと
アッサーダの方が小さいんだと
それだったら人間何を考えるべきかというと
この 3番目のことを考えた方がいいんじゃないかなというふうに
解脱の方に考え方を持っていくんですね
だからお釈迦様は世の中のことを別に否定しても肯定してもないんです
説法を聞くと誤解するんです
なぜならば悪いことばっかり知ってるんだから
だからこれ綱渡りのように理解しなくちゃいけないんです
確かに言っているのはもうすべては苦しみですよと
もう意味がないんだという話なんですけど
でも何と言いますか 悲観主義にならない
だからお釈迦様が計算して
普通の我々の普通の人間としての生き方を見ると
このイークエーションで
この法則でアディーナヴァの方がより大きく
アッサーデの方がより小さいという
あの関係で言っちゃうんです
もしそのこの関係に反論できるならば
世の中ど誰にも反論しても構いません
え 違いますよと言いたければ
そこら辺お釈迦様はもうちゃんとはっきりと言うんです
じゃあ言ってみろと 違うんだと
あるならば なぜそんな風に自慢的に言いますかというと
それぐらい客観的に世の中を見たんだからなんです
だから すごい数学的に自分の人生を見た方がいいんです
デジタル的に 感情でではなくて
感覚ではなくて アナログではなくて
仏教はもう初めからデジタルなんです
厳密なんです 感情が入っちゃうと見えなくなっちゃうんです
例えば 自分には子供がいるとすると
やっぱり子供は可愛いでしょうし
そうすると計算できません
計算できないんだから
やることはほとんど無茶苦茶になってしまっちゃうんです
だから この自分のものという感覚を置いておいて
この品物から私が得る幸福どれぐらいかと
私が得る苦しみは苦しみ
悩み 心配どれぐらいですかと
きちんと数字的に計算してみると
このイークエーションになるはずなんです
なんでその計算できないかというと
やっぱりこんなことやったらなんかかわいそうじゃないかと
だって私の子ではないかとか
いろいろ論理に関係ないもの
感情的なもの言ってしまっちゃう
だから感情と科学は違うでしょ
科学はもう何の感情もない恐ろしいもんなんです
じゃあ痛いんだからやめましょうというのは
医者は言いませんだからね
一応注射しなくちゃいけないんだけど
やっぱり痛い 痛いでしょうと
まあ痛いんだけど じゃあ痛いんだからやめましょうと
医者は言いませんよ ちょっと痛いんだけど我慢しなさいと
そちらに感情が入っちゃうとね
正しいことはできなくなっちゃうんです
そういうわけで この人間っていうのはもう動物だから
やっぱり感情で生きてるんだから
まあ仏教は嫌いです かなり勇気必要なんです
仏教は好きになるためには
かなり勇気必要なんです
そういうことを理解してみてください
そこで この世の中の我々の自分の人生も
自分の関係ある世界のことも
すべてデジタルでデジタル的に見てみなさいと
見たらあなたに何が見えますか？と
そうするといいところは確実に見える
それで悪いところも確実に見えるはずなんです
そこで引き算してみてくださいと
引き算してみたら このアッパッサーダーカーマウッターバゴーターバフアーディーナヴァという答えが出てくるんです
いわゆる皆様にわかりやすくここで書いたんですね
アーディーナヴァは大きいし
アッサーデの方が小さいと
そこはないケースもあるかもしれませんよ
そのイークエーションに入らないケースもあるかもしれません
世の中で まあ私にはなかったんだけどね
一度も  どういうケースですかね
アッサーデの方がアッサーデっていうのはその快楽的な部分ですね
だけあって 苦しみのものは何もないんだとね
まあ例えばそこら辺で散歩をしていると
風が吹いたんだと それで風に紙
ゴミありますね ゴミ一つ飛んできたんだと
まあゴミですから嫌だなと見たっても
それはもう宝くじでしたと
そこで調べてみたら これ 1等賞当たってるんだと
それだったらアディーナもなしにアッサードだけなんですけどね
だから自分買ったことでも買ってもないんだからね
まあそういうことを人生すぐ日常茶飯事にあるんだったら
このイークエーション捨ててください
お釈迦様間違っているんだと
散歩をしていると ちょっと足が滑っちゃって
小石に小石があって そこに引っかかってすごく痛かったと
そこで怒って なんだこの石に引っかかって痛いだろと石の方を見たら
それダイヤでしたと それ拾ったところで大変幸福になりましたと
というならば アーディーナというのはちょっと足が痛かっただけだから
拾ってみたら何億円もかかる値段ある値打ちあるダイヤでしたからね
その場合はこのイークエーションが逆になります
もし皆様の人生の中でそういうものは日常茶飯事よくあるんだったら
問題ないんです そういうことだから
世の中否定することでも肯定することでもなく
この解脱という人間の世界に関係ない
なんかすごい超越した次元のことを話しているんだから
そこはこのニッサーラナというところで観察して発見しなくてはいけないんです
まあ一応そこら辺でそのポイントをまとめて終了しますけど
まあこの解脱の話聞くと
この読む時でも この前の話の同じことかもしれませんだけど
大体の印象っていうのは
まあいいんですと そんなものは
やる気が出てこないんです
もし天国の話聞くと もらうんだったらね
生きるんだったら悪くないという気持ちになるんでしょう
例えば皆様方 キリスト教でないかもしれませんだけど
分かりやすく読みやすくね
まあいっぱい文献がありますから
天国の話やらこの英断の話とか聞くと
まあ仕事をしなくたってもいっぱい死に物なんだかんだもありますで
大変楽しい楽園の話聞くことに
そこから追い出されちゃったんだから
まあ今人間の世界にいるんだけどね
でもほんのちょっとの神の機嫌を取っちゃえば
また楽園に行けるんですね
別に悪くないでしょう
そんな簡単に行けるんだったら行きたくなるんです
他のお話も同じことなんですね
日本の文化から言えば
例えば極楽堂の話を聞くと
ああ それだったら修行しなくたってね
そこを行って解脱できるんだったら
自動的にね で いいんじゃないかと
という風にはなるんですね
もし直接 論理的に 合理的に涅槃の話説明したら嫌になるんです
解脱はしたくなくなっちゃうんです
だからそこは事実なんです
そういうわけで 解脱する人々は少ないんです
別に不可能だから少ないんじゃなくて
ありえない話だからないわけじゃなくて
この修行する人々も自分の心をわかってないんです
ただ 社会と普通に比べて
じゃあ自分が修行するんだとということでやってるだけのことであって
本当に解脱のことを理解して
やっぱり解脱したいというすごい気持ちが生まれてやっているわけじゃないんです
ですから このエネルギーは足りません
持ってるお金も足りません
だから旅は途中で終わるんです
ただそれだけのことを本当に理解しておけば
もうちゃんと解脱できます
ですから お釈迦様の時代では
お釈迦様はすごい迫力があって
ものすごい大胆に説法していたんだからね
まあ私の話も時々大変切っ先例だと思っているかもしれませんけど
そんな調子じゃないんだよ
お釈迦様は ものすごいもう爆弾的で大胆で話したみたいです
聞いたらその場で悟りますから
人々は もう逃げるとこなくなるんです
それぐらい徹底的に言うんです
世の中のことをやらな
だから大お金持ちの人が
ほんのちょっと遊びに散歩をする途中で
ちょっと話でも聞こうかなといったところで
お釈迦様説法を聞いてから
じゃあ出家しますと その場でもう出家してしまう
修行してみますと やりますと
もう家に戻りたくないんだと
そういうふうな態度をとるんだから考えてみてください
ちょっと家から散歩に出ただけなんですけど
もう戻れない そのまま家を出る時はそういう気持ちは全くなかったんです
どれぐらい強かったかと
あの話が 人間だからね
当時も今もね 我々は普通の人間だから
普通でしょう 普通の人間はあれほど心が変わるように話すということは
もう並の説法じゃないと思います
そこでお釈迦様はそれで本家であって
最初の発見者でありましたから
これ分かりやすいんです
まだ自信あって喋られますね
科学的な発見にしたっても
発見者に発見者が講演すると分かりやすいんです
最近亡くなったあのアメリカで亡くなったこの原子でしたっけ？そうそうそうそうそう
ハイかな  一応スウェーデンの人でしたけどね
もともとはね で 彼がものすごい天才でね
たくさん原子も原子という元素とかいくつかもね
世の中でないものは次から次へと発見したりして
だからもう人ぐらいの大統領たちのね
顧問になったりとかね
もうなくなったんだけど
やっぱり喋ると面白いというと
ものすごい面白いんです
あれほど頭が良くて難しい話はしません
だからこれは本物だからね
もし彼が発見したものについて我々は喋ると
いっぱいチャートやらデータやら持ってきて
ああではないか こうではないかと
みんな寝ちゃうんですね
それで難しくて この肝心な本物の人が来ると
寝るところがみんなワクワクして
すごい人でしょと この人発見したんですか？と
そういうものはと見たら普通のおじいちゃんなんですけど
すごいなと で 喋ってみたってものすごいパワーなんですね
そういうことで やっぱりお釈迦様の説法っていうのは
その場で人を解脱できるようなぐらいね
すごい力がありましたけどね
お釈迦様の話 もう聞いてではなくて
読んで いろいろいろんな人から勉強して喋ると
もう何の力もないんでしょうし
難しいし理解できないし
だから真似事でもやろうと思ったらものすごく嫌い
そんな話は聞きたくないと言われるし
そういう問題点はあります
とにかく私がチャレンジしたのは
あの解脱というのは もう学者さえも
まああれは結構だよと
お釈迦様は一応そういう目的で言ってるかもしれませんだけどというくらいのことで
このゴキブリの解剖のような感じで仏教学やってるんであって
このやってみようということは全く誰でもない
誰にでもないんです そこでこのその問題は解決してみようではないかと
いや これはやった方がいいと納得させようではないかという
この私はこのどこ どんな仏教学者にもできなかったチャレンジをね
それから仏教の伝統的なお坊様方にも優柔にさえできなかったこのチャレンジをね
まあやってみようかなと思ったんだけど
またまたどうかなと自分でも考えますけど
まあやるすればいとも簡単にできますけどね
もし覚悟を決めるならば
で いきなり喋り始めますよ
でもどこから壊すかとは私は約束しません
片っ端から壊す その場合は
人間の価値観 判断がどうだとか
自分の人格も何から何まで壊して醜くしてしまって
じゃあどうしますかと
それで答えが一つしかできなくなっちゃうんですね
そこでこの このヴィパッサナー瞑想という瞑想法も
お釈迦様の説法方法も
このこの計算するためのものなんです
世の中のこと だからヴィパッサナー瞑想なんかする場合も
全く判断しないで判断する癖を置いておいて
主観的に物事を見る癖を置いておいて
デジタル的に物事を見て見て見て見ていく
そこでいつでもみんな感覚的で感情的で主観的だから
瞑想自体はまあ苦しいことになりますけど
まあデジタル的にもうなんの主観ももう感覚もなくなくやれば何のことない簡単なもんなんです
そうやってみると 自動的に答えが出てくるんです
解脱するしか方法ないんだと
解脱と涅槃こそが答えですよと
このニッサラの方が見えてくるんですね
だから説法を お釈迦様の説法っていうのは
みんな幸せになりなさいとかね
まあありますけど それほどないんです
よくあの 何といいますか
商売繁盛とかね そうやってこの世俗的な豊かさ
この世俗的な世界にとことんとことん欲を執着を作る話じゃないんですね
そうすると解脱っていうのはもう無意味になってしまうんですね
やっぱりいい家庭を作った方がいいんだと
王様にあなたはしっかり政治できれば立派ですよと
ああだこうだとこの世俗的なことを正当化して喋ると
自分のことどうなる？お釈迦様のことはね
そんなあんたね 我々やってることを褒めるんだったら
なんであんた逃げたんですか？と
そういうことになるでしょう？なんであんたは王の仕事を辞めたんですか？と
なんであんた 自分のおくさんも子供も置いておいて出て行ったんですか？と
家出したんですか？と
人に言う前に自分でやれと
いうことにもなるでしょうに
ですから 人が私は家族で夫婦で喧嘩しているんだと
これは大変苦しいんだと
仲良くなる方法はないかと聞いたら
ありますよと こうこうやって
お互いにこうこうやったら仲良くできますよと
そういう風にこの人が希望すると教えてあげる
そうでないと言わないんですね
じゃあまたあの いろんな立場から解脱のこと
それから涅槃のことを説明いたします
それからこの仏教のあの
お釈迦様の解脱ということが
悟りということは この宗教の世界とはずいぶん違う
ちょっと違うところに立ってるんですね
似ているというか 似ているかな
どっちか分かりませんだけど
このなんか土台が違うんですね
そこら辺ちょっと説明してみようかなと思います
で あの順番で言うのは難しいんですが
一応わかりやすい順番で言いますと
どなたでもご存知 仏教の有名な言葉がありますね
アニッチャという言葉が
アニッチャっていうのは無常という意味なんですね
アニッチャということをお釈迦様はこう言うんです
まあ一応すべてのこのできたもの
構成されているもの アニッチャだよと
無常だよと分かればね
まあそれで終わりだと
それは解脱やと 簡単でしょ
本当に簡単だと思ってください
簡単なんです すべての構成されているものは無常だと
わかっちゃえば まあそこでそこにあるのは解脱ですよと
ですから その言葉から何がわかるかというと
この解脱っていうのはある
心の変換なんですね 我々ここ我々の心がなんかカチンと変換するんですね
裏返しするというか だから確かな経験なんですけど
全ての構成されているものは無常であると
そこでまあそれだけのことなんですけど
そこで私たちがいろいろトラブルを起こしちゃうんですね
例えばこういうこと  構成されているものは無常ですから
構成されてないものは永遠でしょうと
と理屈作る 作られますね
構成されているもの できているものは無常であると
じゃあ構成してないものであるならば無常ではないんです
それはもう単純理屈で論理なんですね
で ですから  永遠なものだったらね
まあ無常じゃないでしょうとか言ったりすることはできますけど
そちらにちょっとした問題があります
実際にあるかないかと
これ実際にないものについて理屈は意味がないんです
あのロジックの場合はシンボリックロジックという分野がありますね
あれは日本語でどういう名前というんですかね
うん えっ 象徴的なえっ？えっ？記号？あ
記号論理学というものがあるんですね
あれ 記号で論理成り立ちと色んなものできるんです
もう人間には考えられないほどの論理も成り立ちますけど
そういうのは全部具体的な実の例に当てはめますかと
当てはまらないんでしょ
だからこの記号論理学
別に論理学は論理学ですから
それご存知の方々は知ってるかもしれませんだけど
まあほとんど数学みたいなもんですけどね
で 実際の我々の生きている我々の実際の具体的な経験に当てはめるかないかと
当てはまるものもあるし
全く関係ない頭だけの記号の組み合わせになる場合もあります
それで今言いたがっているのはこういうこと
構成されているものは無常であるというと
じゃあ構成されてないものはとどうですかという質問なんですね
問題は構成されてないならば構成されてないということでしょ
いわゆるないということなんです
そこを忘れちゃうんです
だから学者の方々も 仏教の仏教を批判する方々も
サンカーラが無常と言ったんだからといって
全てのものは無我や何もないやというのはおかしいんだと
やっぱり実体が魂があるんだと言うんです
仏教でも如来神というものあるんだと
だから人が死んじゃったら何が生まれ変わるんですかと
何か普遍的なものがあるんだと
そこを説明するためにお釈迦様は無常やと言ったんだけど
それはサンカーラのことやと
いわゆる構成されているもののことやと
構成されてないものについては無常でないんだと勝手に言うんですね
それは論理わからない方々なんですね
構成されてないということは
もうないということなんです
まだ作ってない食べ物を食べますやということでしょうに
まだ生まれてない子供に私はおっぱいをあげているんだと
あげられますかね 生まれてない子供だったらもういないでしょうに
だからそこら辺ちょっと明確にした方がいいんですね
まあ一応次に言いますけど
進め続けて 無常であると私たちは分かったら悟るんだと言ったところで
人間っていうのは結構無常ということを味わって経験しているんです
決してこれはあの世の話ではなくて
我々の日常茶飯事の毎日の経験なんですね
毎日 瞬間瞬間 無常というものは味わっているんです
でも悟らない あれ不思議なんですね
だからお釈迦様の悟りというのは
この天国の話みたいもう稀な話じゃ
あれは稀な話なんですけど
鼻の先 目の前にある毎日のあることなんです
1秒単位であることなんです
1秒単位で我々は無常に出会っているんです
それを理解してくださいというだけなんです
だから 私から見れば 解脱ほど具体的ですぐ誰にでも経験できるものはないんです
でも 実際にはそれこそ人間理解しないものはないんですね
修行したっても成功する人々の数が少ないと
なんだこれと 一体絶対
一体全体 まあ例で言えば
我々は空気という海の中にいるんだけど
見たことがないんでしょ
魚は水の中にいるような感じで
我々も空気という海の中にいるんです
空気でないところは一つもないんですね
瞬間も生きていられません
空気がないところに行ったら体爆発しちゃうんです
細胞も 大変なことになるんです
それなのに見たことがないんですね
でも 見たことない たまたまね
体に触れたり 寒く感じたりはします
ああ 空気だと その時は気がつくんです
でも 私たちも魚とかね
海の中に生活する動物みたいに
ずっとこの空気の中にいるんだということには気がつかないんですね
ですから 我々の無常に気がつくことはたまたまなんですね
そこで無常に無常にあっじゃなくて
無常には瞬間瞬間出会ってますけど
気づかないということがあるんです
そこはちょっとした我々の心の問題じゃないんですかね
だから 目の前にあること
海の空気という大気という海の中にいるのに
そういうふうに我々は生きているんだということは
すごい重い空気の中に生きているんだということは知らないということは
まあお釈迦様は簡単なことでも愚か者だと
あんた 愚か者やと言うしかないでしょうに
例えば自分の周り 例えば人がノート書いたくて紙探してるんだと
自分の前も後ろもあっちこっち見る至る所にいろんな紙の種類があるんだと
いろんな種類のものがあるんだと
あるいは自分がこの あの
何て言いますか そういう倉庫にいるんだと
紙をいろんなところに配達している倉庫の中にいるんだと
ちょっとメモを書いたんだけど
紙がないなとか 誰かが買ってくれないかとか悩んだりすると
バカではないか どういっぱいあるでしょうという答えでしょうに
その場合は 例えば自分の前でいっぱい果物があって
やっぱり果物を食べたいなと悩んでるんだったらアホですかと
目の前にあるんで食べなさいという答えになりますね
だからお釈迦様はこの愚か者という言葉は無常についてよく使うんです
愚か者は気がつかないんだと
稀なものだったら そんなことは使いません
例えばエベレストに登る
もう怠け者は登れないとは言えませんよ
あるいは登れる人々はみんな登れるわけじゃないんです
少ないんです 登れる人々
南極に行きたいと思ったっても
誰にでも行けるわけじゃないんです
そういうことじゃないんだからね
無常っていうのはいつでも目の前にあるんだから
それに なんで気がつかないんですかと
気づいてみなさいと 気づいてみたら
そこに解脱というものあるんだと
それで解脱できないのは私たちにある問題であっ
ありますね 心のなんかちょっと変なんですね
その心のちょっとした変なところを直しちゃえばいいんです
それでお釈迦様おっしゃってるその解脱は経験できる
まあ経験してから あれもあまり意味がないと分かったら他のことをやっちゃってもいいんだけどね
すぐ経験できますからね
でもお釈迦様は逆にそれ経験した人はもうこの世の中でどんなものにもにも意味をつけませんと
だから仏教を理解するとか
なんとか勉強するとかより
先に経験してみたらどうですかと
すごくこの一般的なことなんですね
それどういうことかというと
こっちを説明しますけど
我々の見方の問題でもありますね
私たちがこの無常に出会うたびに無常を否定するんですね
無常という事実は否定するんです
拒否するんです 永遠なものを探すんです
そこら辺は理屈で成り立ってないんです
デジタルじゃないんです
感情ですから その無常を拒否することじゃなくて
無常を認めることで悟りが生まれるんです
そこで あの 私たちのすべての努力は無常を拒否するために成り立っているんです
で そこはちょっとあの
まあまだ同じく社会は社会のことを非難するように感じるかもしれませんだけど
これ非難するも肯定することでもなくて
普通のこと事実喋ってるだけなんですけど
人間の一切の努力っていうのは
無常を拒否するためにやっているものなんです
いろいろ例で考えると
なんで我々はいろんな薬を発見したり
いろんな治療方法を発見したり
移植手術まで あのいろいろ科学的な進歩をしたりするかというと
死をとにかく延期するためでしょ
人の死をできるだけ延期しよう
延期しようという努力なんですね
あの だから みんな結局は死ぬんだと
ということは認めたくないんだから
なんとかないかと なんとかできないかということで
そうやって頑張っちゃうんですね
まあはっきり言うと 全部すべて人間の文明
文化っていうのはすべて無常を拒否するためにできているんです
なんで写真撮るんですかね
何のため？あれ無常を拒否するためでしょ？わかってないだけで
なんで子供が生まれたらもう先にするのはビデオを買うことでしょうね
ビデオカメラ買うんです
妊娠したら早く行ってビデオカメラ買おうと
それからもう片っ端から記録する
だからまあ それは人間のやってる一つの側面
このニッサラナという3番目の側面からも見てください
いいもの悪いものばっかり見るんじゃなくて
3番目 今は 3番目の側面で私は説明してるんです
アッサーダ アディーナ ワ ニッサラナ
アッサーダ アディーナはわかりやすいでしょうに
いいところ悪いところだからね
ニッサラナはわかりにくいんです
まあこれからニッサラナの側面で世の中見える方見る方法
だから妊娠しちゃったら妊娠していると思ってございますとお医者さんに産婦人科の医者に言われたら
じゃあビデオカメラ買いましょうということになるんじゃないですかね
それで全部記録する あれはすべて瞬間瞬間で消えるものなんですね
知ってるんです 瞬間瞬間すべて消えている
消えていくんだと 子供は初めて立った時とかね
これ写真撮ったりビデオ撮ったりして大喜びするんですね
立った立った立てた立てたと
面白くも何でもない あれで一生立ってるんだから
歩いたりする でも両親にとってはそれはすごい出来事なんですね
で そこは記録する 止まってもらう
無常に逆らってるんです
どこか行ったら あ 綺麗やと思った
じゃあ写真撮ろうと ある有名な人に突然どこかで 2 3秒会いましたと言ったら
早くちょっとスナップ一つ撮ってもらうんですね
2 3秒のことだからね
それにしたくないんです
あれは永遠の思い出にしたいでしょ
そこで人間の努力っていうのははっきり言うと何ですかね
無常に逆らうことなんです
無常に無常を見ることではないんです
だから悟りにくいんです
誰に逆らってるんですかね
私たちはこの空気に大気に逆らってることと同じなんです
逆らってどうなるんですかね
そういうことで このまあ
ご自分で考えるとわかると思います
私は説明しちゃうと なんか嫌なことばっかり言うんじゃないかなと思うかもしれません
だから遠慮しますけど
あの人間だけではなくて
この動物も同じなんですけど
必死になってこの無常に逆らってるんです
戦ってるんです でも勝てません
これはいくら逆らっても
だから死にたくないんだからご飯食べてるんだけど
動物も でも死ぬんです
それで人間だけこれ知ってるんだからね
死ぬっていうことは 何かないかなと
死なないことは そこで宗教みたいなものができちゃうでしょう
この魂があるんだと 霊魂があるんだという概念も
そういう もう幼稚的な概念なんですね
全然証拠ないんです 全くないんです
証拠は みんな魂あるなと思うのは
これ自分の感覚と記憶なんでしょ
例えば 1 分前でやったことはきれいさっぱり忘れるんだったら
自分というアイデンティティさえないでしょうに
あの その記録する能力がなくなっているある男性の番組がテレビで NHK で放映したんですね
前 あれはなんとか病気で病院に行ったところで
このまあ 病院の方でね
点滴やってるともう高カロリーのね
ものばっかり入れちゃったりして
脳がどこかでまあ壊しちゃって
壊してしまったんですね
普通のすごい健康な人なんですけど
何にも覚えておくことはできません
だからすごいおかしいんですけど
人はすごくきれいな顔をしてるんですね
何も覚えてないんだから
世の中のことは だから何も苦しみない顔なんです
だからどれぐらい忘れると
自分の子供の頃 自分の子供かとも忘れちゃうんです
だから奥さんが必死になってもう全部ビデオ撮ったりする
奥さんの場合はこれ なんかすごくもうかわいそうというかね
子供のことも忘れちゃったらどうするんですかとかね
そこは奥さんが無情にとにかく逆らってみようと
そこで本人にいつまでもビデオを見せたりするんですね
そこで本人 あれ自分だと全然感じないんですねと
もうほんのちょっと前やったことなんです
自分だと全然感じませんと
なんか別な人の人みたいだと
だからそこで自分って一体全体何ですか？という疑問が生まれるでしょうに
私たちにとってはこの記憶はあるんだから
覚えているんだから自分だと自我があるんだと思っちゃうんですね
もう一つ 感覚的には死にたくないんだから
霊魂あるんだと思った方が気持ちいいんですね
それは希望だけなんです
それでこの 我々この我々のパーソナリティという人格というか
アイデンティティというかね
そういうものは記録なんですけど
不思議なこと それ変化するでしょ
覚えているものを忘れるんじゃないんですか
すべて覚えているわけじゃないでしょうね
気持ちいいところだけ覚えているでしょうに
自分の名前とか それからもう小さい時楽しかったこととかね
子供のかわいかった時のとことかね
そればっかし覚えているでしょうに
それ好き勝手に一部一部を選んで
長い人生の中で適当な都合より都合によりいくらか選んで覚えておく
覚えているんだったら
お釈迦様の全部を覚えておきなさいと
すべて それやらないんでしょ
お釈迦様もこの厳密な記憶力っていうのはすごくいいことだと言っているんです
厳密に それ瞑想してでも育てなさいということもあるんです
覚えるんだったらいい加減ではなくて
明確に細ごとに覚えておいた方がよろしいし
我々はそうじゃない すごい好き勝手
それでそう覚えたものも忘れる
それから人格どうですか？変わらないんですかね
人格はぐるっとぐるっと変わっちゃうでしょうに
だから 両親たちがよく悩む問題っていうのは
この 10歳まではね 子供たちの人格はみるみるうちに変わるでしょう
赤ちゃんの時の性格と
それで 1歳飛んだところで
3歳  4歳まではもうわがまま放題でどうしようもない
すごい自己主張する歳で
それで 6歳ぐらいになってくると
よく物事を理解できて
そこで子供はすごく両親はすごくほっとするんですね
すごく可愛いんだと 何の問題も心配もないんだと
そこでまた 12歳  14歳になるとどうですかね
全く人格変わるでしょうに
それで 18歳になると
20歳になるとどうですかね
自分の子供たちは 16 18 20
歳になる人々は やることを親が知ったら親が自殺するんです
それぐらいのことをやっているんです
世界の中で ですから 人の人格っていうのは
これ自分の子供なんですけど
みるみるみるうちに変わるもんなんです
そこに自我があるんだと
永遠の何かあるんだと思うのは自分の希望であって
事実ではないんじゃないかなと
そういうことで このそういう宗教の世界で霊魂魂だとかだと出てくるのも
お釈迦様から見れば あんた方は無常に逆らっているんだと
無常を認めたくないんだと
そこで質問が現れます
無常に逆らってもいいんじゃないんですかと
例えば優れている科学があるんじゃないかと
それ無常に逆らったんだからでしょうに
優れている医学の世界あるんじゃないかと
それは無常に逆らったんだからでしょうしと
人は絵を描くのも同じことでしょ
あれはまあ消えるものは永遠にしたいんだと
残しておきたいんだと
だからまあ美の世界あるんじゃないかという反論することはできます
どう答えればいいんですかね
そこであれ計算してみなさいと
無常に逆らうために自分が払う苦しみと得る幸福はどれぐらいですかと
無常に逆らうために 我々は永久的に苦しみを味わわなくちゃいけないんです
そこが問題なんです だから逆らえないものだから
で 永久的に努力しなくちゃいけない
終わりがないんです いつでも無常だから
いくら逆らっても 次にまた逆らわなくちゃいけない
次にまたやらなくちゃいけない
そこは輪廻という言葉なんです
終わりがないんだと もう逆らってみなさいと
乗り越えられませんと
だから 大雑把に物事を見ると
私は病気になった 苦しかったと
それでいい薬がありましたと
飲みましたと 治りました
ああ 幸せだと いう答えが確実にあります
それも正しいんです それは嘘じゃないんです
病気になって苦しかった時
薬飲んで治ったっていうことは
でもそこにあるのは大雑把な見方だけなんですね
この順番に コマごとに物事を見たわけじゃないんです
で そうやってほんのちょっと成功しましたと
あるんだけど そういうのは瞬間的なんですね
だから確実にアッサラだというもの
幸福というものはありますけど
残念ながら瞬間的なんです
次にまた戦わなくちゃいけないんです
終わりがないんです いい薬飲んだんだからといって
あなたは死ぬまでもう二度とその病気にはかかりませんということもないし
他の病気にかかりませんということでもないんですね
心臓発作を起こしたところで
もうすべてシステムができているんだから
救急車なんて言いますか
もうそういう救急車やら電話しただけでちょっと飛んでくる
それでパラメディックのあれなんとか変なものだったら
車の中でちゃんと緊急治療して
ちゃんと生き返ってもらったと
これは確かにありがたい話なんですよ
もし昔風にだったら 人が心臓発作を起こしたら
じゃあお医者さんのところに連れて行きましょうと
みんな運んで こういうなんとか籠で持っていくと
あの振動でもう死んでしまっちゃいますけどね
今はそんなことはなくて
電話した途端家に来て
すぐその人を運ぶ前にもちゃんと酸素を入れてあげたりして
それなりの注射したりして
もう生き返ってはくれます
確かにそれはもう素晴らしいことなんですけど
じゃあその人は二度と心臓発作を起こしませんかと
その人は死なないかというと
その瞬間では乗り越えたんだけど
また同じ問題に出会う
出るたびに戦わなくちゃいけないし
最終的には負けると そこはどうしようもないことなんです
だから この無常に逆らう過程によって
我々は損二つしているんです
一つはよく覚えてください
無常に逆らうことによって損二つしているんです
一つは 私たちはそれによってずっと苦しまなくちゃいけない
逆らえないものに逆らっているんだから
戦えない相手を敵に回しているんだから
ずっと苦しまなくちゃいけない
それが1番目  2番目 物事を見えなくなる
知恵が発達しない 鈍感のまんまで終わっちゃうんです
その2つの損が生まれてくるんですね
だから このお釈迦様がおっしゃっている
このディジタルの世界
主観的でなく客観的な世界
なかなか無理でしょう
あれは長い間 我々は無常に逆らってきたんだから
私たちは鈍感なんです
じゃあこの2つ もうちょっと説明考えてみましょう
無常に逆らうと並ならぬ苦しみを味わわなくちゃいけないんだと
例えば ものすごい簡単単純な例で考えましょう
ある若い男の人がすごい気に入っている女の人と結婚したとする
気に入って 気に入ってもそれだけでいいんじゃないんですか？瞬間みたいな
気に入った かっこいい
かわいいんだと でも逃げちゃうでしょ？無常でしょ？だからそれで写真だけ撮って我慢しないんです
だからそういう女の人じゃああんたすごく私にとってはすごく可愛いんだと
私の好みのタイプだと
ですから もう写真ぐらい撮らせてくれと
はい ありがとうございますと
それで終わらないんでしょ？無常でしょ
相手が だから自分のものにしたくなる
捕まりたくなる 逃げられないようにしたくなる
あれはなぜそうなるかというと
無常だからなんです それで結婚するでしょ
じゃあ結婚したんだから
ちゃんと届け出しましたから
これで私のものやとなりますかね
ならない それからもその人はずーっと気をつけて気をつけて生活しないと
あの女の人に逃げられるんですね
あるいは逃げられないんだったらずーっと自分を苦しめるんですね
どっちかなんです そこでその若い男の人は
それからまあ時間もいろんな苦労をしなくちゃいけないんですね
気をつけなくちゃいけないし
言葉はすごく気をつけなくちゃいけないし
だから夫婦の間でも この言いたい放題のことを言うのは女性の場合だけでしょ
男の方々みんな知ってるでしょうに
正直に言ってください
いくら夫婦喧嘩したっても
ものすごく言葉に気をつけるんじゃないんですか
女の人だけ言いたい放題ことは平気で言うんだけど
男は言いません ものすごく気をつけるんです
女の人平気で言うんです
あなたと結婚して大失敗しましたと
でも男は言わないんです
だからまあ  私ももう一応同じ種だから
あの気持ちは分かります
なぜ言わないかっていうことはね
だからかなり頭の中でいろんなものを考えて考えて考えて
気をつけて気をつけてとか
この間テレビでちょっと見たんだけど
なんとかの何人でしたっけ
あれは梅宮さんという人
で 彼があの まあなんか夫婦喧嘩しますかというと
だから聞いたら まあ出ていけとかなんとか言いますかと
そしたらなかなか夫婦喧嘩はしますけど
出ていくら喧嘩したっても出ていけとは言わないんだと
その場合はあまりにもエスカレートしたら俺が出て行くんだと言うんだと
なぜかというと やっぱり向こうには行くところがないんだと
だからこれすごい感情を高ぶって
もうものすごいお互いにエスカレートして夫婦喧嘩する瞬間なのに
その瞬間でも気をつけるんですね
言うべき言葉と言ってはいけない言葉と
修行としてはいいことなんですけどね
自分をコントロールするということだからね
そういうことはだから悪いとかいう意味じゃないんです
悪いかいいかということではないんだけど
やっぱりそうやって大変な出来事なんです
その結婚したその日で全て終了しましたとというハンコを押して終わったわけじゃないんです
いつでももうファイルはオープン状態なんですね
ファイルクローズということはできません
その事件は終了しましたと
終了しませんね 何一つも
だからそうやって ずっとこの無常に逆らうということによって
我々には終われない大変さ
苦しみというものは生まれてくるんですね
苦しみっていうのは 苦しい
苦しいという意味でとってはいけませんということも覚えておいてほしいんですね
もう大変だと やりきれないんだと
いくらやってもまだやらなくちゃいけないんだと
何やっても不完全やとという意味なんです
まあもう二度とやらないんだと
二度と来るなと言える時は気持ちいいんですけどね
でもそれできないんです
例えばもういつでもお金を貸してくれ
貸してくれという誰かがいるんだったらね
まあその人と関係なくてもいいやと思った瞬間ではね
もう二度と来るなと あんたと関係はもうこれで終わりだとは言えますけどね
その時はしっかりしますけど
でもそういうケースも
ないんでしょうし なぜならば
いつでも来てお金ちょっと貸してくれ
貸してくれという人も
何か我々をどこかで何か握ってるんですね
だから貸してあげなくちゃいけないことになっちゃうんですね
だからいくら貸してあげたってまた来るでしょうし
例えば自分の子供にしたっても
まあちょっとお金ちょうだい
お金ちょうだいというならばね
もう大人だから自分のこと自分でしなさいと言いたいんだけどね
じゃあ二度と来るなと
はやっぱりまた言いたくないでしょうね
なぜならば 自分にとっては自分の子供だから
そこら辺で愛情 感情というものありますからね
だから喧嘩しながら いろんな文句言いながらあげません
ああだこうだと言いながら
なんでそんなお金使いますかとか
いろいろからくりからくりばっかしで
それで子供くれるんだったらはっきりいえ
くれなさい くれよと それで親もなんでそんな態度とかね
だからあげるかあげないか
どっちかはっきりしないんです
その場合は だからそうやっていろんなややこしい生活を我々はしています
これはどんな人間の生活もそんなもんなんです
はっきりとこのもう白黒決めてる人生はありません
世の中で ですから そこはどこからそんな問題が生まれるかというと
この無常に逆らいたいというすごい高い次元で見ると
哲学的な目で見ると ディジタルな目で見ると
無常に逆らっているということなんです
本当は自分の子供というものは存在しない
自分のあれはおかしいんです
自分の子供じゃないんです
顕微鏡で見ても やっと見えるぐらいの自分の体の一部っていうのは
そんなにも我々執着するべきもんですかね
デジタル的に考えてみてください
精子卵子っていうのは
もうもう何て言いますか
受精しなかったら全て死ぬでしょうに
男の体からそれはもう使わないものは全部溜まってるわけじゃない
それはもう自動的に体から出ていくんでしょうし
女性の場合もそうでしょうし
寿命は女性の場合は 1週間ぐらいでしょうしね
わからない はっきりと
もう男性の場合も精子の寿命っていうのはものすごく短いんですね
死んじゃうんです 死んだものは他の細胞と同じく
もう体から出ていくんです
ああ 私のものやと思うんですか？一度でも
時々怪我して怪我したりして
血液も出ていくでしょうに
ああ 私の血液やと思う人がいないでちゃんと拭いて捨てちゃうんです
時々ガンなんかになったらそのまま取って捨てたるでしょうに
1キロ  2キロぐらいのもの
それなのにちゃんとデジタル的に見ると
もうどうったことはないんです
でも見ないでしょ？見たくないでしょ
やっぱり私の一部やと思いたいでしょうしね
そういう風にこのものは変化するんですね
変化することを認めてない
それで この細胞は私のものだと
思ったりして その細胞も分裂して変化して死んでしまっちゃいますけど
新しい これも私のものだと
そうやって無常を無視して
これ私のものやと思っちゃう
それ思う気持ちだけ それによって我が子やと思う気持ち
ただ無常に逆らっただけなんです
それから自分の子供に対するすべての苦しみを味わらなくちゃいけない
同じことで 私のお金だよと
私の健康だよと 私の体だと
全部私の 私のという言葉使ったら
私たちはそこで苦しみの地獄を作っているんです
だから私のというものは
その概念を捨てた瞬間は解脱だと
解脱を説明するもう一つの言葉なんです
私 私の 私のもの その概念
心から消えた瞬間が解脱ですよと
そこを消えたところで
他人と戦わない 対立はしない
何によっても困ることはないと
[背景音楽]そこでだからこの無常に逆らうことをね
そうやって並ならぬ苦しみが生まれてくるということの説明でしたけど
二番目の説明にいきます
何といいますか あの鈍感になるんだと
これは説明しなくてもね
無常に逆らうことだから鈍感なんですね
まあ例えばこの富士山の写真を撮ったりする
それを見て富士山の写真だとすぐ思っちゃうでしょうに
あれは富士山の写真じゃないんです
目ではっきりと見ると
それは紙であって 紙の上にいろいろ色の物質がついているだけなんです
私たちにとっては同じ富士山の絵であって
それによってああ綺麗だという感情も生まれてくる
自分の写真を見ても まあドーハン
やっぱりなかなか綺麗やと
そうやって本当はそうでないのに
あの鈍感なんですね ですから
ものすごく この まあ本当はこの
まあいつでもそういうことだからね
やっぱりすべて無常なのに
逆ろうということで鈍感になってしまっちゃう
見えなくなってしまっちゃう
お釈迦様の修行の世界では
もうここら辺 この心の機能をなんとかしてね
きちんとした人にしてみようとかと
で 解脱が得られるんだと
だから解脱を得た人は究極的な幸福の塊を感じるんじゃなくて
究極的な平安を感じる
驚くべきものは一つにも出会わない
その人は 苦しむべきものにも一つにも出会わないのです
ものは流れているだけ
だから心にはこの 究極的な平安が生まれてくるんだと
そこでこの解脱ということを説明する場合は
あの肯定的な説明をするところでは
お釈迦様はわかりやすく言うのは
この自分がおっしゃっている
解脱ということは このすべての苦しみの終了だと
ケーワラッサドゥッカッカンダッサパハナナンなんですね
だからこの嫌だと思うのはものすごく意味がないんです
解脱する人は損するものは何もないんです
ただ苦しみの巨大な苦しみを捨てるだけなんです
巨大な苦しみを捨てるだけ
そこで可能ですよと ほんのちょっと心変えれば
その可能であることはちょっと説明します
それはこの一切は無常であるという立場から
もう一つ 一切は苦であるという言葉もありますね
どっちでもいいんです
一切と言ったっても 世の中は無常であろうがなかろうが
私にとっては関係ないんだからね
私という個人が自分のことしか考えませんからね
世の中が火事になろうが
地震が起ころうが 自分は安全だったら別にもう問題ないし
だから 自分に関係なかったらいいでしょうに
別に 例えば宇宙の中でいろんな出来事が起きてるでしょうに
関係ないんだからね 別に勝手にどうそうということで
だから関係あると困りますけどもね
南アメリカで地震が起きたって別に関係ないんだけど
ここで起きちゃうとね
困るんです であの だから一切無常である
苦であるという場合は
一番肝心なのは自分が苦しみであって
自分が無常であるということなんですね
世の中よりも 私は無常であると
私は苦しみであると で
そこは大体みんな何言おうかと生命は知ってるんです
このお釈迦様がおっしゃられている基本的な真理は
生命の心の中できちんと刻んであるんです
否定できません 毎日の経験だから
瞬間 瞬間の経験だから
だから私の心が全てが無常であるということを本当は知っている
そこなんですね このポイントは
だから可能なんです 解脱するのは
で だから自分は絶対死なないんだということは心にはないでしょ
死にたくないんだから
認めたく 認めないだけのことです
それで自分の人生を見ても
いろんなことを変化していく
大体なんで人間に不安があるんですか？変化するんだからなんです
ちょっと不安だと 心配だと
もし人が私には何の心配もないか
ないとなんの不安もないんだと
何の不安もないんだというと
二人しかいないんです
究極的な馬鹿ものか 解脱しているか
どっちかなんです いわゆる精神薄弱みたいなアホか
それは失礼な言葉なんですけど
その方が そうじゃなくて
もう全くもう馬鹿ものか解脱しているか
どっちかなんです 人間には不満いっぱいあります
不安いっぱいあります
心配ことはいっぱいあります
で なんでそんな心配不安出てきますかというと
やっぱり変わるんだと分かっているんです
変わっちゃうんだと分かるんです
次にどうなるか分からないと
それ知ってるんです 一旦
例えば就職しましたと
そこでホッとして まあやったと
これでもう一生と思ったら危ないでしょうに
そう思う人はだいたい無知で
もう頭能力ない人でしょ
大体頭ちゃんと鋭い人々はもうもう一応就職したんだけど
毎日頑張らなきゃあかんと知ってるんです
仕事うまくいくかいかないかとずっと不安なんです
自分の仕事はちゃんと会社の役に立ってるかないかと
それは心によく効くんです
もし自分の仕事は全然会社の役に立ってないと分かってしまっちゃえば
あれはすごい苦しみでしょうね
ああ どうしようか すごい不安になってしまうんです
だから心は知ってるんです
この無常ということを
でも悟らないとこだけちょっと問題があるんだと
だから まあまあ冗談で言うならばね
いろいろこのごろいっぱい悩み事あるんだなと言うんだったら
すごい良かった あんたすぐ悟りますよと
悩み事あるんだったら
でも悟らないでしょう
そんなところじゃないんだと
悩んでる 悟るところじゃないんだ
だから悩み事 心配事 不満とかいろいろあるということは
無常であることを心が知ってるんです
永遠じゃないんだと 会社に就職したっても永遠じゃないんだと
結婚したっても それ永遠じゃないんだと
いつでも子供のことで心配あるし
他のことで心配あるし
いろんな自分の体のことで心配事あるし
それでだったら悟ればいいでしょう
苦しみ消えるんだから
悟ったら全ての不安は悩みは苦しみですべて蜃気楼のようにさっと消える
泡のように消えるんだと
はじけるんだと すべて
それはお釈迦様ちゃんと言うんです
悟った瞬間で まあ今までやった一切の苦しみは
精神的な悩み 苦しみ パンと消えてしまっちゃう
でもそこは体験できないので
そこら辺何でしょうかと
こういうことなんですね
人間のやり方がちょっとまずいんだと
ある経典で言ってるんです
不安感じる人が 例えば自分の体
無常でしょ すべて無常でしょ
変化するでしょ そう知ってるんです
知ってるんだから何とかしようとはしているんです
その何とかしようとしていることは
我々の生きることでもあるし
文化も文明もすべてなんです
これすべてこの不満 無常であることに何とかしようとしていることなんですけど
お釈迦様曰くのこのやり方
ちょっとおかしいということなんですね
どういうことかというと
私の体が無常だから エネルギーが出ていっちゃうんですね
それで体にエネルギーが必要なんですね
わかりやすいえばお腹がすいたということなんですね
そこでお腹がすいたんだったら
答えはご飯食べること
もう決まってるんです
そこでご飯食べるでしょうに
計算してみてください
ご飯というものは無常でしょ
それで体無常でしょ 無常だから入れるんでしょうに
無常をなくすために 無常をなくすために入れたものも無常なんですね
だから答えがあってはないんです
それは 答えにならないんです
だからもうまたご飯食べなくちゃいけないんです
だからお腹がすいたということは
無常という現象なんですね
このニッサラナという第3番目の立場から見ると
そこで取ったご飯も全く無常なんですね
だから無常をなくそうと思って無常を受け入れてもなくせるわけじゃないんです
そこで必死になってみんな頑張ってはいるんです
だから無限的に頑張らなくちゃいけないんだ
いくら頑張っても無常の苦しみはそのまんまですと
だからこの話は この頭もデジタルで考えないと理解できないんです
デジタルで考えてください
宗教みたいに考えちゃわなくて
まあ違う例で言います
私の体が壊れかけている
当然そうでしょう 壊れかけている
体というのお釈迦様ある時はこのバブルの塊に
泡の塊に例えているんです
泡の塊だから塊ではありませんね
泡だから そこで泡だからケチンがはじけてはじけてはじけていくんだと
そこで泡がはじけると穴が空きるでしょうね
そこでもうちょっと泡を取って入れておく
そこで他のところ 泡がはじけると
そこで穴が空けるんだから
また泡を取って入れておく
これで何年やるんです？それは
いつ止まるんですかね
いつ不安がなくなりませんかね
泡がはじけたら危ないんだと
自分が死ぬんだと 終わりがないでしょう
だからお釈迦様言うのは説法経典でこうあるんです
老いること 病気になること
死ぬことで 我々は並ならぬ苦しみを味わっているんだと
同じことなんです 別にこの生老病死というのは宗教的な言葉ですから
わかりやすいんですから使っているでしょうと思いますけど
本当はお釈迦様科学的なことを言ってるんです
老いるということは変化ですからね
それで我々は並ならぬ苦しみを味わっているんだと
それで探すんだと これなくそうと思って
苦しみをなくそうと思って何か探してるんだと
何を探すかというと 老いるものを探しているんだと
死ぬものを探しているんだと
病気になるものを探しているんだと
だから終わりがないんだと
そこで答えは 老いることで苦しんでいるならば
その年取らない 老いることないものを探さなくちゃいけないんだと
病気になるのは苦しみであるならば
病気にならないものを探さなくちゃいけないんだと
あれ 探して探し求めたもの自体が病気になってはならないんです
死にたくない人が探し求めたそのものが
死なないものでならなくてはならないんですね
そこでお釈迦様がもう悟る前にみんなそうやって探しているんだと
それは間違っている探し方だと
私は これどうしようかと
やっぱり老いるものをみんな探してるんだから意味がないんだと
それを説明する 何が老いるものかというと
もう財産 家族 そういうものだとみんなやってるの
いくら探しても苦しみは消えませんと
ですから それをやめて
清らかな世界 幸福な世界
平安な世界 全く老いない
老えない不死なる世界
不死なる境地 そういうものは探し求めて
もう発見して体験しましたと
だからその場合はニッバーナという言葉を使っているんですね
アジャータン アジャラン
アマタン ニッバーナという言葉を使っているんですね
それで私たち あの 現代的な話に戻りますけど
あの 私の現代的な話では
経典そのものはわかりやすいんです
正直に言うと だから直接すってん言いますけど
あの この聖なる探求というマッジムニカーね
中部経典にあります アリアパニサーナという経典
パーリ語の名前 この名前なんですね
訳もあります 中部経典でね
読んでみてください 中部経典の第一部
で あの 現代的な話に戻りますけど
私たちはこの壊れて壊れかけているものなんですけど
その それをやめるために修理するものも全部壊れかけてかけているものだから
終わりなくもう苦労しなくちゃいかないんだと
修理の終わりがないんです
いつでも修理をする 修理をする
だからやり方変えてみたらどうですか？と
どうやって変えるかというと
この体が泡の泡の塊のようにバブルなんですね
泡ですね だから弾けて弾けている
これ嫌だと思ったら何かして修理しなくちゃいけない
それで泡でできているものだから
当然泡取らなきゃね 修理できないでしょうに
同じものでなきゃ そこで泡を取っちゃう
取って入れても この泡の塊がどうなるんですか？まだ弾けていくでしょうに
大変だ もっと泡持ってきて入れておきましょうと
だから修理する場合は同じものを入れなくちゃいけないので
だから我々はご飯を食べる時も同じものを食べてるでしょうに
同じものというのは体を構成している同じものでしょうに
違うものを食べたらご飯になれませんしね
そこで修理するならば
泡そのものを取って入れなくちゃいけないし
泡取ったらこれまた弾けて消えるし
また修理したければまた泡そのものを取っていかなくちゃいけないし
これで終わりがあるんですかと
問題解決しますかと なぜ泡壊れるのは嫌かというと
泡壊れるとすっごく心配する
体が壊れると苦しみが味わう
あれなんですか？と だから泡を取って取って修理する
修理した瞬間には良かったと思っちゃいますけど
次の瞬間でまたバブルが弾けて弾けていきます
そこで次にまた入れると
そのやり方 このニッサーラナという第3番目の立場であっさだあでぃのはニッサーラナ
第3番目の見方で見てみようと
3番目の見方で見てみるんですね
こういうこと 泡だから弾けるのは当たり前でしょうに
ああ 心配だと なんで弾けてはいかないと思ったんですかね
あれが間違いです 泡の出来た泡でできている体で泡が弾けるんだから
穴が開けちゃうでしょうし
ああ 大変だと それで新しい泡を入れる過程でしたでしょ
そこで問題は自分のバカバカらしさにあるんですね
これ 泡でできているんだから弾けたっても
ちょっと時間止まってたっても
どうでもいいでしょうに
心配することはもともとなかったんです
本当は 苦しむことはもともとなかったんです
今までやってきたこの泡入れては修理する
また入れては修理 あれは全く無駄な努力でした
そういう自分のアホらしさに気づいてもらったら
それでその境地は解脱なんです
あ 心配することはなかった立場から
あれは泡でしたと ですから
無常を体験しましょうと
無常を体験したら あの心にあったあのすごい膨大な苦しみ
心配はさっと消えていく
だから あまり解脱についても心配する必要ないんです
何も損することはないんです
今も得してもないんだからね
人生は 何も それなのに解脱したら何か損するんじゃないかと
自分の仕事もなくなるんではないかと
奥さんを捨てなくちゃいけないんではないかとか
くだらんことを考えますけどね
何も捨てることにもならないし
取ることにもならないんです
今も得したわけないんでしょ
はっきり言うと人生で
苦しんだだけでしょうに
だから解脱しちゃったら
この心はすっと安らぎを感じちゃうんですね
なぜ解脱は永遠かというと
本当は永遠なもの何一つもないんです
ありえないんです あ 元々なかったという発見なんです
だから 悟りという経験を得た人は
なんだこんな こんなもんかと
本当にバカバカしさに気がつくんです
それは智慧なんです こんな単純で
これに気がつかなかった
これ何のこともないんだと
ああ わかってよかったと
別に自分として何かすごいものを得たわけでもないし
何かなくなったわけでもないんです
ただ あ こちらにあったのは泡でできていた塊やと
心配することないの 泡だから別に
どうせ弾けるんだから
もし まあちょっと面白おかしいんだからね
ふざけてもっと泡入れてみようかなと思ったら
それ別にどうってことないんです
あれはふざけてやってるんだから
だから もし皆様方は悟ってからも必死になって仕事をしてみようとかね
頑張ってみようとか思ったっても
まあもうふざけてやることで
別にそれは苦しみにつながりませんよ
どっちでもいいことだから
だから泡が大事なものやと思って
これ壊れた 大変だ もう心配だ
もっと泡入れましょうということで修理すること自体がバカであって
まあどうせ泡だから  まあちょっと面白いんだから
もうちょっとこの入れてみようかなと
思ったら それは別に壊れたっても
別に大きくなったっても
別にどうってことないんですね
ただそれだけの差なんです
だから わかりやすく言えば
普通の悟ってない人は
仕事をする時は一大事のこととして
人生もうこれしかないような感じで
精神的にストレス溜まったりして
髪の毛は全部落ちたりして
で このアドレナリンばっかり出したりして
ビクビクして やってるでしょう
もし悟ったならば 何のことなく
もうすごく気楽に軽々と
ちょっとした子供のあのカルテ遊ぶような感じで
やるんです やりたくないと思ったら
まあいいわ もうくだらんことやめたと
やめることもできるし
どっちでもできます でも
かすかにでも神経質になったり
苦しみを感じたりはしない
だから 私は昔 まあいい加減なことを喋ったものはね
本になりましたから 人生はゲームですと
あれではこの本当はあの
ゲーム論は語ってないんですけどね
そのゲームというこのゲーム論はあります
これ喋ると哲学になりますから
僕はできるだけもうそこら辺はもう遠慮するんです
で ただそれだけの答えはゲームだと
勝っても負けてもどうってことないと
悟りも同じことなんです
で 皆様にその時言ったのは
日常生活のこと そんな気にするなと
ゲームだからルール守ってやれと
それだけのことなんですけど
でも 悟りということも同じことで
存在自体も単なるゲームであって
ちょっとやりたいなと思ったらやってもいいし
やっぱり途中で面白くなくなりますからやめた方がいいと
それだけのこと ゲームだとわかってないんだから
これもうあまりにも真剣にやっちゃうんですね
真剣にやるってやる必要ないんです
ムキになると言うかね
時々我々も子供たちとゲームやっちゃうとね
ムキになる人々いるでしょうね
あれ気持ち悪いでしょ
でも時々面白くするために私もムキになる時あります
でもわざとそうなんです
わざとなるんであって
ちょっと子供とちょっとなんとかゲームやったところで
ほんのちょっと自分の点数なんか下がったら
すっごく大げさにオーバーに悔しがっちゃうんです
悔しがってもう一夜やりましょう
いいあんたとやりませんと
これぐらいになったんだから
とんでもない 悔しいんだと
そうすると向こう側がものすごく喜ぶだけなんです
だからってわざわざ真剣勝負
別にそんなことじゃなくて
まあただ遊びで まあそれもふざけて
ですから すごく生きることはもう大変幸福に楽しくはなるんですね
だから まあ日常生活の中ではゲームですということは
ゲームなんならゲームなんですけど
日常生活 でも悟りの行持でも
存在すべて すべての一切のものは無常ですよと
バブルですよと 泡ですよと
作られたものですよと
組み立てたものですよと
だから壊れるんだと ああ
ムキになる必要ないんだと
もともとがないんだと
自分という体に対しても
他人という世界に対しても
そこはわかっていただきたいだけのことなんです
だから ちょっとしたこの我々のやり方はまずいんだと
それを変えてくださいと
だからこの悟りの世界は
この逆流を行くという言葉ありますね
その逆流に行くということは
その場合は流れは世の中の人々の生き方なんですね
世の中の人々の生き方と一緒にいてしまえば
毎日苦しいだけ 真剣になってゲームやってるんだから
死活問題だと思ってるんだから
なんのこともないのに
ですから そこに逆らえと
そんなムキになって この壊れかけてる泡に新しい泡を入れ替えることだけでしょ
みんなやってるの 誰でも
そこはムキにならなくてもいいんだと
泡ですよと理解する だから逆流というんですね
そこでまた逆に悟る世界は寄る
寄るかというんですね
寄るどう寄るかと いわゆる流れに入ったんだと
あれはどういう意味ですかね
世の中の流れに入ったという意味ですかね
じゃなくて すべては無常で流れてるでしょう？私たちは無常に逆らってるでしょう？だから苦しんでるでしょう？だから川を泳ぎたければ
川は激流の川であるならば
それに逆らって反対に泳ぐと泳げないんです
疲れて疲れて疲れて  1センチも進まないんです
そこで溺れて死んじゃうんです
だから無常だと 流れていくんだと
激流だと 放っておけと
放っておいたらどうなるんですか？その人も川と一緒に何のこともなく流れていくんです
だから 1 センチじゃなくて
どこまでも進むんです
だから流れていくのに泳ぎたいと思うならば泳いでもいいんだけど
それバカバカらしいだけなんです
激流に逆らわないで 流れと一緒にいるんだと
流れと一緒にいるだけでもいいんです
それでもちょっと手足を出して泳ぎたいなと思ったら
泳いだっても苦しくはないんです
それで悟っている在家の人と悟っている出家の人の差がそちらにあるんです
悟っている出家者はこの流れにいるんです
だから流されていくんだからね
在家の人々は在家の世界でいるんだから
やっぱりちょっと商売でもしなきゃ食べていられませんし
子供たちやら奥さんがいるんだったら
それぞれいろいろ面倒見なくちゃいけないし
人間関係あるんだからね
まあそれはちょっとやってみるだけのことで
まあそれもバカバカらしいなったら
その人々も出家しますけどね
でも最終的に悟った人は出家するんです
本当にバカバカらしいと
たとえゲームにしたっても
一生やれないでしょうに
面白くないんですね 例えばカルタとカルテとか何とかというゲームやってるんだと
これ  1時間  2時間は面白いかもしれません
ですけど これは朝起きて
朝ごはん食べて ずーっと昼ご飯までやって
それから昼ご飯食べて
それでずーっとやって
また夜ご飯食べて また12時までやると
やれますかね それぐらい
いくらゲームセンターとかところに行って遊んでいる若い人々でも
毎日はやりませんし 何時間もやりませんよ
嫌になってしまいますからね
ですから やがてこのバカなゲームはまあいいやということにはなりますけど
それをまあやりますから
それはまあ死んだ瞬間でもう永久的にその問題って終わりますから
ですから 涅槃には種類がありますからと
一つはソーパティセーサ・パラニッバーナ
もう一つはアヌパティセーサ・パラニッバーナ
ソーパティセーサ・パラニッバーナ
アヌパティセーサ・パラニッバーナとこの解脱のことを二つに説明しているところがあります
で ソーパティセーサというのは
例えば人が知恵発達して修行でもして
無常ということを体験して
やっぱりすべて無常やと
そうすると このバカバカらしいでしたということはわかったとする
悟ったにしても その人は体があるでしょ
それでも 体があるということは
この体に関係ある他の体たちもあるでしょうに
人間というよりは そこで体はもう泡の塊だから弾けていくんですね
だからその人は体がある限り
泡が弾けたらまた入れてはおく
穴が開けたらまたそこへ入れてはおく
その大変さがありますと
悟っても 体があるんだから
違うところは これ真剣
真面目に必死になってムキになってやるものじゃなくて
まあどうせ泡の塊やと
だから弾けるのは当たり前だと
でもちょっとこちら弾けてこっち穴が開けたんだから
もうちょっと泡が入れようと
泡入れようと入れて この体の面倒は見続けるんです
自分に体があるんだから
自分の体に関係あるものいろいろまた体がいっぱいありますでしょうに
ですから そういう人々の問題もあるんだったらそれも見る
でもあれはムキになること
苦しむことは全くない
もう泡ですよとわかっちゃったんだから
今まで我が子やと思っていた泡の塊がいたならば
悟ってからはこれは我が子ではなくて
もう一つの泡の塊やと
で そちら泡の泡が弾けているんだったら
そちらにも何かお手伝い助けてあげて
それは穴を埋めるようにはしてあげる
だから行動的には全然変化が起きません
人が悟っても 自分が毎日自分の子供にご飯を作ってあげたならば
悟ってからも同じことするんです
変わったのは心の苦しみが消えただけなんです
そこでソーパティセーサ・パラニッバーナと言うんです
アヌパティセーサ・パラニッバーナっていうのは
それでいくらこの泡の塊は泡が弾けて弾けている
いく それで新しい泡が入れていく
そこででも切りがありますからね
そこでどんどん弾けるスピードが速くなる
すごく速くなる そこでいくら泡を取って入れても
ものすごい強烈なスピードで弾けていって死んじゃうでしょ
死ぬっていうのはそういうことでしょうに
体で壊れる細胞の数が大きくて
成長する細胞が少なくなる
そこでどんどん成長 新しく生まれる細胞もなくなっちゃうんですね
そこでまあ二 三週間で死ぬ
だから死ぬ間際になってくるとご飯食べないんですね
食欲なくなっちゃうんです
新しい細胞生まれませんから
そこでまあ一週間ぐらい内で死んじゃうんですね
そこでそんな働きで自分の体壊れていっちゃうんですね
まあそれで終了と それはアヌパティセーサ・パラニッバーナと言うんです
でもこれ発見しない人々には心配する必要ないんです
無限に仕事があります
無常に逆らうと だから死ぬ時は他の人々は悔しくて死ぬんです
逆らって逆らって逆らってみたんだけど
ダメでしたと ああ 悔しいと
生きてきた 生きてきたいと
むきになって頑張ったんだけど
死んじゃうでしょ 不完全な心で死んじゃうでしょ
だから悔しくて もう一度やるぞということで輪廻転生するんです
そこでまた逆らうんです
また悔しくて死んで またやるぞとやるんです
だから まあ解脱したくないと思うならば
永遠に無限大に輪廻で頑張れる
よく頑張れますし で 無常を発見したら
もう全部この無限大の苦しみが消えてしまうという差なんですね
どちらでも別に評価というものはないんですけど
輪廻したければそれはそれでよろしいし
でも苦しみは確実にある
で お釈迦様から答えとして言うならば
人間というのはこんなくだらんことをやめてみた方がいいんだと
ということで話を終了したいと思います
どうもありがとうございます